Hey youtubers, it’s Charlie.
Hopefully everyone’s had a chance to see
Episode 9 and process a little.
Because Ra’s Al Ghul is such a big thing
this season I wanted to do a bonus breakdown
of the most important stories I think you
should read and an explanation of the Lazarus
Pit.
He’s appeared in over 500 Issues, and not
all of them were Batman Titles.
But most of his best stories are Batman stories.
I tried to pick stories I think are really
good and are relevant to what’s happening
on the show.
So general spoiler warning for Arrow episode
9.
Here we go, Top 5 Ra’s Al Ghul Stories.
Number 5 - Tales Of The Demon Collected Edition
Number 4 - Death And The Maidens
Number 3 - Tower Of Babel
Number 2 - Birth of The Demon Trilogy
Number 1 - Daughter Of The Demon
Now just to explain the Lazarus Pit a little
more.
Ra’s Al Ghul’s origin story explains that
he found the pits as a young man completely
by accident while trying to save a prince’s
life.
He was completely healed, but as a side effect,
left completely insane and ended up killing
Ra’s wife.
Ra’s was framed for the murder and given
the death sentence of being forced to wander
the desert.
He found help and eventually began to use
the Lazarus Pits over and over.
There was a pit called the Fountain of Essence
that had different effects.
It healed Ra’s Al Ghul after he’d been
dead for a long time.
He didn’t go insane, but he did come back
in a really old feeble body.
Batman used it when he had minor wounds and
it de-aged him a little.
Another character was with them and when he
tried to use the Fountain it killed him.
So not all the pits are the same.
But usually when someone refers to the Lazarus
Pit, they’re referring to the traditional
ones.
And yes, there are many all over the world
in the comics.
There was even a period where Batman and Bane
traveled around trying to destroy them all
so Ra’s wouldn’t be able to keep healing
himself.
But as expected there were a bunch of hidden
ones they never found.
There have been a ton of characters that have
used a Lazarus Pit including:
Black Canary, she used it to restore her Canary
Cry powers and her ability to bear children.
Nyssa Al Ghul
used
them
to stay young and to warp Talia’s mind.
She’d kill her and heal her over and over
to brainwash her.
Lady Shiva, Dick Grayson, The Riddler and
Mr Freeze have all taken advantage.
Because Arrow is really conservative with
how they do superpowers, it’s possible we
could see a twist on the idea of resurrection.
Oliver seemed like he should have died when
he tumbled off the cliff.
But in the promo for episode 10 we see someone
approaching his body.
Clearly he’s going to come back.
So what I think will happen is someone will
just nurse him back to health and use some
extra powerful techniques.
I don’t think we’ll see the traditional
Lazarus Pit.
I do think we’ll see some easter eggs, the
show will acknowledge it, but I don’t think
Oliver will be bathing in green fire anytime
soon.
A lot of people have pointed out Malcolm Merlyn’s
necklace here.
The Green Vial as being a potential easter
egg for the Pit.
It’s possible he’s the person we see in
the promo and he’ll save Oliver as a way
to repay him for wiping his debt with the
League.
John Barrowman made some comments about filming
Episode 9 and he said he was in a very cold,
windy place.
Implying that he was filming scenes on that
mountain top set.
Since we didn’t see him there in the episode,
the evidence points to him being the person
right here.
Let me know if you agree, do you think Malcolm
Merlyn will
be the one
to save Oliver?
And What’s your favorite Ra’s Al Ghul
Story?